this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
Apple has recently released their brand
new 16 inch MacBook Pro so we've now got
Apple's complete lineup of Mac books
that shouldn't change at all until at
least the end of spring starting with
the MacBook Air for $1,100 the base
searchin ish macbook pro for $1,300 the
higher-end 13-inch Pro for $1,800 and
the new 16 inch macbook pro for $2,400
to make it even better each one of these
math books is now around $100 off from
Amazon with free prime shipping if used
the links down in the description so
definitely use those if you want to help
support the channel now let's get
started with comparing literally
everything we can between all of these
Mac books starting with portability in
terms of weight the 16 inch pro is now
4.3 pounds and it's very noticeable
compared to the rest of the lineup from
above the air is basically just as large
as a 13-inch pro so portability should
be pretty similar and the 16 is pro is
even less portable than the old 15-inch
the MacBook Pros also have more of a
flat slate shape compared to the MacBook
Air which has a wedge design that gets
thinner near the front end each of these
math books has a high quality retina
resolution display but the AERS display
isn't as nice it's quite a bit dimmer
than the pros that each have an
incredible 500 nits of brightness and
it's definitely not as color accurate
since every MacBook Pro has p-3 wide
color gamut which has about 25 percent
more colors than 100% srgb which is a
must-have for photo editors as far as
display sharpness they all have around
the same retina quality 227 pixels per
inch and every macbook in the lineup
comes with true tone technology which
adjusts the white balance of the display
to match the environment around you the
big change this year is that the new 16
inch pro now gets smaller bezels that
actually look quite a bit nicer and more
modern compared to the rest of the
lineup speaker quality and volume is a
huge deal for some people especially for
me so here's a sound comparison so you
can hear the difference for yourself
[Music]
there's overthinking
[Music]
we noticed that the air has slightly
worse speakers than the base searched an
inch pro and the higher-end $1,800
13-inch Pro gets even better speakers
but the standout model is the new 16
inch with a new 6 speaker design with
incredibly good sound quality and bass
so definitely buy the 16 inch if you
love great speakers it also features new
studio quality microphones so here's a
FaceTime comparison of all of them this
is a microphone quality test with a
13-inch MacBook Air this is a microphone
quality test with a $1300 13 inch
MacBook Pro this is a microphone quality
test with the $1,800 13 inch MacBook Pro
this is a microphone sound quality test
with a new 16 inch MacBook Pro now onto
the keyboards the 16 inch MacBook Pro
finally packs Apple's latest magic
keyboard compared to 4th gen butterfly
keys on the rest of the MacBooks there
is seriously a light and a difference
between the two you get so much more key
travel and it's a much better typing
experience on the new 16 inch now there
are rumors that the rest of the MacBook
lineup should be upgraded to the new
magic switches next year but it most
likely won't happen until at least
spring time apart from that the MacBook
Airs keyboard slopes downward towards
the front edge so it's actually a bit
more comfortable to type on compared to
the pros and every single MacBook and
the line up comes with a touch ID sensor
built into the power button which makes
it really convenient to log in use Apple
pay online and install apps off the web
without having to enter your password
however every MacBook Pro comes with the
touch bar an Ola display that replaces
the top row of keys and is fully
customizable but not that many people
like it because it's more difficult to
do things like adjust the display
brightness and volume and one of the new
benefits of the 16-inch pro is that it
actually gets a physical Escape key so
if you're a programmer or someone who
uses that key a lot definitely go for
the 16 inch pro now let's talk about the
port's every pore on every macbook this
year supports Thunderer both
but both the 13-inch MacBook Air and
lower end MacBook Pro come with only two
of these ports compared to four ports on
the more expensive pros if your basic
user that doesn't connect to external
displays or connect external devices
very often you'll probably be fine with
one of the two port models and you also
have the choice of buying a Thunderbolt
3 hub just in case you do need more
ports but having 4 of them from the
get-go is definitely more convenient
especially for those who use those ports
more often now if you love large
trackpads the 16 inch pro has the
biggest one of them all followed by the
13 inch pro and then the air that has a
slightly smaller trackpad for battery
life the new MacBook Air is rated at 12
hours compared to 10 hours on the
13-inch pro's and 11 hours on the 16
inch macbook pro so all the air is the
best option for battery life the 16 inch
pro is still a great choice now before
we get into comparing performance let me
first tell you about our sponsor
Squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
Squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
I built an engaging website for my
wife's cleaning business with literally
no web making experience you just choose
a template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and it's
been running flawlessly for almost two
years bringing in new clients thanks to
the built-in SEO tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
for literally anything else go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and use
our custom link below when you're ready
to launch - save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain getting
it to performance the base $1300 macbook
pro finally gets a quad-core processor
so the MacBook Air is now the only one
in the lineup with a dual-core CPU the
$1,800.00 pro has a faster quad core and
the 16 inch pro has a 6 core that can
actually be upgraded to an 8 core if
you're willing to spend another $300
looking at RAW processing power using
Geekbench 5s multi-core test we can see
that the MacBook Air with this dual-core
CPU is way behind the MacBook Pros and
surprisingly the $1300 Pro performs
almost the same as
eighteen hundred dollar model in the 16
inch gives you a pretty good jump in
performance as well so we decided to
look at performance per dollar using the
full retail price of each math book and
the new $1,300 based MacBook Pro comes
out way ahead with incredible amounts of
raw power for the cache with the air
being a very bad value performance wise
one thing that you won't find on a spec
sheet is at the $1,300 base MacBook Pro
has only one fan just like the MacBook
Air while the more expensive $1,800 and
$2,400 pros have dual fans and the 16
inch pro has even better cooling than
the 15-inch so it should perform way
better for longer workloads to test that
we ran Cinebench r20 a more realistic
benchmark which is long enough to heat
the systems up and see how well the
cooling systems work and surprisingly
the single fan on the $1300 pro didn't
really limit performance like we thought
it would so we're really impressed with
it in the 16 inch was the clear winner
in terms of performance we then tested
graphics performance using Geekbench
wise metal test in the 16 inch pro
completely destroyed the rest of the
MacBooks because it's packing the new
AMD Navi dedicated graphics ship it
almost triples the graphics performance
of the $1,800 pro which is insane and as
you can see when looking at graphics
performance per dollar the 16 inch pro
now destroys the rest of the lineup in
terms of value for graphics power insist
the 16 inch pro has such a good graphics
chip we decided to test gaming
performance using Unigine heavens
extreme preset and it completely
obliterated the rest of the lineup with
more than four times the gaming
performance of the $1,800 Pro so if you
want to do some gaming on the side
definitely buy the 16 inch macbook pro
we also tested SSD speeds and here we
see a pretty big difference when going
to the more expensive MacBook Pros
especially the 16 inch pro because it
comes standard with a 512 gigabyte SSD
but even the less expensive models are
still fast enough for most people so if
you're still confused on which macbook
you should buy let me break it down for
you
the $1300 based 13-inch MacBook Pro is
by far the best choice if you want to
spend less than twenty four hundred
dollars on a new
book thanks to its excellent performance
per dollar and overall macbook
experience now if you don't really need
a great display or high performance and
you'd rather save a couple hundred bucks
you can definitely go for the MacBook
Air instead the air is great if you're a
writer a student or someone who just
wants a premium reliable laptop for
doing basic computer tasks like web
browsing working with documents and
sometimes watching some Netflix as well
as getting some extra battery life out
of it but to be completely honest I
personally cough up the extra $200 and
just get the pro anyway since you get a
better display but our speakers and
awesome bang for your buck in terms of
performance
now that $1,800 13-inch Pro is in a
really tough spot because it honestly
isn't that much more powerful than the
$1300 Pro it just has a few luxury
improvements like an extra two
Thunderbolt three ports faster SSD
speeds and extra cooling fan and better
speakers the only downside of the $1,300
pro is that it only comes with the 128
gigabyte SSD and even then I still think
is a better value to upgrade to 256 gigs
for an extra $200 instead of getting the
higher-end 13-inch Pro I would honestly
recommend everyone to completely ignore
the $1,800 Pro and buy the new 16 inch
pro instead because you're getting so
much more with thinner bezels the much
better magic keyboard the better
microphones better cooling and much more
performance with the six core processor
brand new dedicated graphics and you
actually get a 512 gigabyte SSD at the
base $2,400 price instead of spending an
extra $200 to get it on the high-end
13-inch pro the only reason you should
buy the $1,800 13-inch pro is if you
absolutely must have a 13-inch for
Portability and you don't think the
$1,300 model is enough for you and even
then I would still recommend buying the
lower end 13-inch Pro or going straight
from the $2,400 16 inch macbook pro
which gives you incredible value for the
price it's got the best speakers the
best microphones and more importantly
much more performance with options of an
8 core CPU up to 64 gigabytes of RAM
massive 8 terabytes of storage so there
you have it if you're still confused on
which one to buy comment down below and
we'll help you out and if this video
helped you make a decision make sure you
use those links down below to buy and if
you want to see more videos on the new
16 inch macbook pro check out one of
those two right over there and click the
circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]